one of the big sort of story lines that
we've been following in particular over
the last six months over the last year
certainly been the kind of trump era is
the reality that the modern American
right wing and the Republican Party have
this list of stated values which mean
almost nothing to them as soon as the
values start to conflict with the real
world circumstances and the specifics
and the outcome that they want they
claim to have values which they
immediately abandon as soon as those
values are inconvenient to the policy
that they want or to their perspective
on any kind of particular issue I have
another example of this for you today
which is a republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green and this is really
serious the reason that this is the
first story today is that this is really
really serious Marjorie Taylor green is
now suggesting saying that there should
be a sort of grace period or cooling off
period when Democrats move to a red
State film from a blue State before they
should be allowed to vote now this goes
against all election law voting law
enfranchisement of Voters in the United
States it goes against everything not
even from a logistical standpoint it
goes again even the idea the values of
how this country works and how voting
works and it is in fact a sort of
California version of the great
replacement Theory which comes from
France which we're going to talk about
in a moment so let me go through this
piece by piece a Newsweek reporting
Marjorie Taylor green calls it wise to
Bar Democrats who move to Red States
from voting
what
if red States and blue states were to
divorce each other that's the word she's
been using representative Marjorie
Taylor green called it possible that
people who moved from a Dem state to a
Republican state would be barred from
voting for a temporary quote cooling off
period what is this about well
California Newsweek rights has seen an
influx in people moving out of the state
many going to Texas and Florida where
residents get more bang for their Buck
however some including green have
complained that those who are leaving
California bringing their political
beliefs with them and potentially
Shifting the political landscape
yesterday she posted on Twitter
brainwashed people who moved from
California and New York need a cooling
off period her comment was in response
to a Twitter user who supports uh who
wrote he supports discriminating against
Democratic transplants including
restricting their ability vote to devote
for a period of time Marjorie Taylor
green wrote on Twitter all possible so
Pedro Gonzalez wrote I support actively
discriminating against transplants
through legislation they shouldn't be
able to vote for a period and they
should have to pay a tax for their sins
and Marjorie Taylor green added to that
saying after Democrat voters and big
donors ruin a state like California
you would think it wise to stop them
from doing it to another great state
like Florida brainwashed people that
moved from California and New York
really need a cooling off period This is
not legal there is no legal basis for
this they say that they are fighting the
left's voter fraud
absentee ballot massive dumps of votes
you guys know all the stuff it's we're
sick of it by now and that they are all
about legal voting well when you move to
a new state you can legally vote there
right away there is no legal basis there
is no constitutional basis there is no
ideological and I mean by that the idea
of the founders of this country by which
you should be restricted from voting
when you move for some period of time
and this is part of the full-scale war
on our voting institutions that
Republicans are waging this is not like
an offhanded joke
when we talk about the coup attempt when
we talk about all of that in the context
of 2020.
um she believes this she believes this
and there's a really good chance that
many of other many of the other
Republicans and trumpists believe it as
well we can't laugh this off they don't
want democracy they want to pay lip
service to the idea of a Democratic
Republic
um when in reality what they want is
their sort of authoritarian tyrannical
uh rule by what is increasingly a
shrinking minority ideologically and
that's an important thing to remember
ideologically these people are
increasingly in the minority this is the
great replacement Theory applied to
California we've talked about the great
replacement Theory before
um this is uh this comes from France uh
this is a white nationalist conspiracy
theory it was disseminated by the French
author Renault kamu and it states that
with the complicity or cooperation of
replacist Elites the white French
population and white European
populations at large this is from
Wikipedia are being demographically and
culturally replaced with non-european
peoples and at the time from the late
19th century when this originates they
were talking about Arabs berbers Turks
and sub-Saharan Muslims through Mass
migration
um we have talked about Tucker Carlson
paying lip service to a sort of American
version of the great replacement Theory
when he talks about immigrants coming
from typically Central and South America
making the country dirtier and poorer as
he says and the idea of Democrats
wanting to bring as many of these folks
into the country to get them to vote to
win elections that's the great
replacement Theory just applied from
19th century France and Europe to the
United States in the 21st century
Marjorie Taylor Green's fear-mongering
is based on the same principle which is
they're going to in this case it's
liberals
and what were the words that she used uh
um brainwashed liberals
who have committed sins coming from
California and New York to Florida and
Texas and presume you know maybe her
state of Georgia as well it's the same
idea it's the idea of this uh uh plague
or dirty infection from outside coming
in and replicating and taking over our
states Like A Parasite attaching itself
to a host it is the exact same line of
thinking 19th century France Tucker with
brown people from Mexico Marjorie Taylor
green liberals from California and New
York going to Florida and Texas
um and uh if we ignore it if we ignore
it this stuff will continue to take hold
because if Marjorie Taylor green is
saying it it's because a bunch of her
constituents already believe it and we
know that they do so that's her idea
um we are of course horrified to see it
but at the same time need a strategy to
activate against it not the voting piece
there's no legal basis for what she
wants but these ideas are sadly
spreading and not only are they
spreading it's becoming more acceptable
to say it in public which is a big part
of the problem
one of our sponsors is Magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals I loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon They're bringing
back cookies and cream They're bringing
back Maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as I do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com Pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code Pacman at checkout